il ya besoin de diversité en plus il ya
besoin de sociologie supplémentaire est
différente et je crois que c'est
important pour l'assemblée nationale les
députés ne sont pas assez représentatifs
la diversité sociale à l'assemblée
nationale c'était mieux avant eh bien
oui
au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale le parti communiste et le
premier parti de france largement
représentés à l'assemblée nationale la
classe des employés mais aussi des
ouvriers est bien présent au total 12,5
pour cent d'ouvriers c est ça restera un
record et 6,2 pour cent d'employés
décidément ce que tu as apporté du
nouveau très rapidement cette courbe
s'effondre mais elle repart à la hausse
en 1958 ouvriers et employés font leur
retour dans l'hémicycle une diversité
nécessaire selon ce député
je crois que le fait d'avoir dans une
assemblée des personnes provenant
d'activités de professions différentes
est extrêmement important parce que
chacun fait bénéficier les autres de son
expérience et cela me paraît quant à moi
extrêmement effet parfaitement des 100
sièges
doucement mais sûrement les
fonctionnaires et autres professions
libérales vont prendre de plus en plus
de place dans l'assemblée et dans les
années 80 alors que la gauche est au
pouvoir
la chute du nombre de salariés et
d'ouvriers continue de quoi inquiéter ce
sociologue et des catégories qui sont
peu là il se trouve qu'il ya
pratiquement pas pratiquement pas
d'ouvriers et d'employés c'est aussi un
sacré problème des partis ouvriers qui
sont voulus ouvriers qui ont essayé de
remédier à ça le pc s'effondre à chaque
législative le ps s'embourgeoise bilan
en 1993 les députés d'origine ouvrière
passe en dessous des 1 % alors quand un
ouvrier fait son entrée à l'assemblée
nationale ça devient un événement l'idée
vient surtout les gens avec qui je
travaille qui m'ont dit il faut que tu
montres que tu représentes le monde
ouvrier et ça serait bien pour la
première séance y allant de travail bon
j'ai accédé à leur demande même avec le
retour de la gauche en 2012
l'assemblée ne compte presque plus aucun
ouvrier alors lorsque le parti la
république en marche promet de
renouveler la politique un certain
espoir animait les députés c'est un
grand honneur pour moi c'est beaucoup de
fierté aussi d'incarner le
renouvellement dans la vie politique
française un renouvellement oui avec 75%
de nouveaux députés mais on repassera
pour le renouvellement sociale car c'est
la première fois qu'aucun ouvrier elle
est élue au coût de ces nouveaux députés
sont issus du monde de l'entreprise le
nom de chef d'entreprise devrait par
exemple être multipliée par 2 devrait
être une cinquantaine le nombre aussi de
cadres d'entreprises devraient bondir
d'un tiers 0 % d'ouvriers à l'assemblée
nationale alors qu'ils représentent 20%
des français 76% de cadres et de
professions intellectuelles
alors qu'il représente 17,1 pour cent de
la population niveau représentativité
sociale les députés ont déjà fait mieux
[Musique]